Hi, everyone,
I’m Anu Srivastava,
and I'm going to show you
how you can use Vertex AI
to train and serve a TensorFlow model
using code in a custom container.
We’ll be using a dataset
of technical specs of automobiles
to build a model that can predict
the fuel efficiency of late 1970s
and early 1980s cars.
You can find this dataset on Kaggle.
We must provide the model with descriptions
of several automobiles from that time period.
The description includes
attributes like cylinders,
displacement, horsepower, and weight.
We're working mainly in a notebook.
So, think of this as an interactive Web tool
where you can combine
code, computational output,
text, and multimedia resources
in a single home.
We’ve set up a container here, a portable
environment to work with our model.
Don’t worry, we have all the source code
and instructions for you in a codelab
to try this out at home.
Now that everything's set up in here,
let's train the job on the platform.
I can go here to the Trainings tab,
create new job.
I’ll name my demo,
add a few other settings
like our container URL and compute specs,
and now it's off to the races.
This one actually takes
10 to 15 minutes to train.
I ran a job ahead of time
so we can test it out together.
So now that it’s trained,
we deploy an endpoint,
and we can now use this
back in our notebook.
Now for the moment of truth.
Let's predict a sample.
I’ve added a cell
down here with a sample case.
This is a set of attributes
that we described earlier,
but they've been normalized,
which is why they don’t look exactly like,
say, a year, or the weight of a car.
I hit run, and we can see
that an automobile with these values
would give us approximately
16 miles per gallon.
To make this visual, I can use a lot
of ready-to-go functionality
to visualize my data down here.
Use graphs and charts to share
your findings with your friends.
We hope we’ve inspired you
to try working with your own data,
or to re-create this demo,
check out the links provided.